to work out anything about a cylinder
we'll look at volume later on but for
today we're just thinking about the
surface area this is how much space the
whole surface would take up if I
unfolded it okay you need to know two
piece of information to work out
anything about a cylinder you've got to
know its size so para is circular right
the base and the base of the top when
you're working out when you're
describing the size of a circle what's
the usual piece of information you give
to say this is a bigger a small circle
you need the radius right so let's draw
on here I'm going to put a in fat dot to
indicate the center and when you go up
to the circumference
there's the radius okay so you need to
know how wide this thing is that's the
first piece of information but this
cylinder it could be like a really fat
squashed one down the up or it could be
very long it's also what other piece of
image do I need I need behind there okay
now these two pieces of information are
what we're going to use to work out so
if your same thing for volume worry
about surface area first now remember I
said to you like it's like if you
practice like if you literally go
wrapping paper and wrapped it it's like
how much wrapping paper what you need
okay
now there's an easy part and a trickier
part of this the easy part first is
think back to the very first exercise
you did back in this unit we said we're
looking at curved things okay so you
have top of the bottom and they are both
circles right so the surface area is
going to be the top and the bottom
which are just going to be circled and
then there's one wasp in the main part
actually how would you describe that
nothing goes around yeah we'll get to
that name
usually it's called the curved surface
area because the top and bottom are flat
but this part is what wraps around now
I'll get to the character surface area
in a minute let's just talk about the
top the bottom the top in the bottom are
congruent to each other they're exactly
the same size and shape at least you
cope so if it's a cylinder how do I work
out the area on the top of the bottom
yeah I need the radius what are we going
to stick into one formula unit property
- its PI R squared right and there's a
top and a bottom most so it's actually
per squared times - I'm gonna write the
number as okay so what Tommy bottom but
then till we get this curve in it well
it's a little bit tricky we need to
visualize this so I thought I can do
better than kitchen - imagine I thought
okay I thought okay well this is what a
soda looks like right um you've worked
out the top you've worked out the bottom
which is the same and then it's this
part that goes around which is the
tricky part
okay so someone already mentioned right
it's like well if I were to like just
thing apart okay let's get the top of
the bottom off don't cry it's alright in
15 minutes of my life and then getting
back if I take off the top and the yeah
I know if don't just just wait you'll
see I take off the top in fact I'm not
gonna
I put this in here and if I take off the
bottom when you see what's left which is
hollow because I'm not very good at
constructing these things so the
solution is I know add more tape once
you once you've separated out the top of
that's right it's like would you like
some wrapping paper with that tank that
is the tank all right now have a look
guys have a look at this stay with me I
want to know how big this thing is
right so you can actually see if you
split really hard what I constructed
this out of right what shape was it
before it was this round and the answer
is if you slice it down where I
originally had it okay so I mean it
could be a square but I think it'll be a
pretty a pretty fat looking cylinder if
it was now here's my question right you
already have told me about to play us
with that's fine okay it's a rectangle
what is the area of a rectangle its
length times breath right so he's the
he's the Langguth jianchi okay and the
breath were using these guys that have
brought it okay now think about it this
right
actually I'm oriented it the wrong way
this is um it was unwrapped right so it
used to be like this so I'm holding it
up right according to what our cylinders
look like on the page so actually when I
unwrap it like this have a look at let
me um let me rewrite my layers have a
look at this distance up and down can
you see where this distance here
corresponds to on this diagram you see
I think this is a light here this is how
flying my cylinder what do you agree
it's right you'd like to be installed
now this wimpier how do I find out what
this width was where did it come from
the answer is it's raised it used to be
around this thing you guys are so easily
amused
okay now you can't even see my tape
right can you see the tape so therefore
where did this come from
it's all the way around do you see that
I see this man
it's the circumference that's exactly
right wait a second wait a second how do
I work out circumference it's 2 pi oh
right
okay so now that you told me now that
you told me what the area of the two
circles are what's the area stretching
and that's that it's not complicated
right
in fact it's more than Isis most
memorable formulas it varies in in
measurements
so yeah the to Klaus swear that's the so
cool to play our H that's the curved
part